[Music]
the 2017 I Heart Radio Music Awards were
full of electrifying performances fierce
fashion and memorable speeches Justin
Timberlake one song of the year for
can't stop the feeling his acceptance
speech was funny yet poignant if you are
black or you are brown or you are gay or
you're a lesbian or you are trans or
maybe maybe you're just a [ __ ] singing
boy from Tennessee anyone that is
treating you unkindly it's only because
they are afraid or they have been taught
to be afraid of how important you are
Bruno Mars slayed his performance before
accepting the innovator award he
promised fans the best is yet to come
innovators are very is a very heavy word
and this award is I'm so honored it's a
little ironic for me because I genuinely
feel like I'm I'm just getting started
so Coldplay scored the honor of best
tour they definitely had the cutest
speech of the night if it wasn't for
this one weird-looking guy we would give
One Direction some good competition DJ
Khaled also pulled on our heartstrings
he brought out his infant son Assad to
help introduce ed Sheeran and
Harmonizers May fifth harmony proud
after 39 million votes the girl group
took home the award for best fan army
you guys are truly a force to be
reckoned with we love you too
thank you for being so much joy and
kindness and love to our world but the
true MVPs of the night the Cyrus family
ET was inside the award show we spotted
Billy Ray and Tish chatting with several
stars miley snapped a pic with Big Sean
and Noah went wild when Chris Martin
joined the chainsmokers
[Music]
you